hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute möchte ich euch zeigen
wie ein in drei stunden gartenarbeit das
komplette obst und gemüse für eine
familie an wochen kann so machen wir das
nämlich wir bauen unser gemüse komplett
selber an und wir bauen alles obst was
man in unseren breitengraden dann bauen
kann für unsere familie selber an also
keine orangen und bananen natürlich aber
äpfel birnen zwetschgen ihr wisst ist
alles gut was man hier ohne probleme an
bauen kann war wir für uns selber an und
dafür brauchen wir eben drei stunden in
der woche was erstaunlich wenig ist wenn
ihr den kanal noch nicht abonniert habt
dann macht das jetzt hier unter dem
video auch immer die glocke drücken dann
bekommt ihr bescheid wenn ich neue
videos posten
ich mache videos rund um das thema
selbstversorgung aus dem garten da gibts
jede woche neue spannende tipps für euch
und jetzt legen wir los und ich erkläre
euch wie man einen garten möglichst
pflegeleicht gestaltet wir haben
ungefähr 300 quadratmeter mietfläche
aufgeteilt auf zwei gärten ungefähr
zwischen zehn und fünfzehn obstbäumen
die wir pflegen und beenden und ja das
ist schon ein ganz großer garten da
waren einige von euch erstaunt dass das
wirklich nur drei stunden pro woche
kostet den garten zu bewirtschaften und
das ganze obst und gemüse für unsere
familie selber anzubauen
das war natürlich nicht immer so am
anfang als ich diese ganzen techniken
die ich jetzt verwende noch nicht kannte
als ich noch gar keine erfahrung hatte
im gemüsegarten da hat es ungefähr 15
stunden pro woche gedauert das alles zu
bewirtschaften und das ja dass das jetzt
so einen riesen unterschied macht zeigt
mir einfach dass es super wichtig ist
dass man ein bisschen struktur dahinter
hat dass man sich wirklich überlegt wie
man einen garten pflegeleicht gestaltet
man spart sich super viel arbeit wir
müssen kaum noch ließen und die müssen
kaum retten also wir haben eigentlich
gar kein unkraut im garten außer wenn
mal unkrautsamen eingeflogen kommen wir
zum beispiel löwen zahlen dann kennen
die sich natürlich ansehen aber wir
haben alle unsere beete so angelegt dass
von unten also auf der wiese gar kein
unkraut mehr hochkommen kann
weil wir das durch kompass auflage
unterdrücken und so super pflegeleichte
beete haben die jahrelang unkrautfrei
bleiben ohne dass man großartig was
machen muss außer ab und zu den löwen
zahlen und die anderen um kräuter die
wirklich von außen einfliegen können
also wie kandidaten mit ihm schirmchen
team ist man ab und zu noch mehr gelten
aber solange das unkraut noch klein ist
also wenn man da einfach ein bisschen da
bleibt dann dauert das paar minuten im
rudel hatten das ganze ist erledigt aber
am anfang weiß ich noch dass es nicht
super überfordert hat ich habe immer das
gefühl gehabt ihr garten wächst mir über
den kopf ich komme mir überhaupt nicht
hinterher wir hatten auch keinen
wasseranschluss im garten das heißt wir
mussten jeden tropfen wasser
dahinschleppen in dem kanister und das
war immer nur ein tropfen auf dem heißen
stein also das wasser hat vorne und
hinten nicht gereicht wie walsum kraut
gewachsen ich wusste überhaupt nicht wie
ich das gemüse da überhaupt noch
erkennen soll in dem dschungel und es
war ja es war so schade weil ich habe
spaß an meinem garten aber ich hatte
einfach nicht die zeit 15 stunden die
woche da hinterher zu sein und ständig
auf den knien durch die beete zu haben
ja dann habe ich mich zur mission
gemacht herauszufinden wie man einen
garten pflegeleichter gestalten können
weil ich hab es einfach nicht geschafft
so viel zu gärten denn ich konnte ich
bin überhaupt nicht hinterher kommen mit
dem hohen grad dann war schon wieder
schlecht weil ich es nicht hingekriegt
habe so viel zu gießen ohne
wasseranschluss im garten weil es
einfach gar nicht möglich da hinterher
zu kommen und dann habe ich bücher
gesetzt ich habe youtube kanäle durch
gesucht
ich habe ganz viel in der uni gezielt
vorlesungen dazu genommen wie man einen
garten möglichst gerecht gestalten kann
ganz viel aus der kultur übernommen ganz
viele unterschiedliche methoden
ausprobieren mit einer
verglichen mit einander verbunden und so
mein eigenes garten system entwickelt
das wirklich darauf ausgelegt ist dass
das ganze reibungslos funktioniert die
möglichst ohne gießen und ohne jeden und
das ist dass drei phasen garten system
das sich entwickelt habe also alle die
in meinem gemüsegarten staaten kurs drin
sind ihr kennt in drei phasen garten
system dass das system nach dem wir
gärtnern und daraus werde ich euch jetzt
fünf tipps vorstellen
die wirklich super supermarkt dabei
helfen einen gartenpflege recht zu
gestalten ein ganz großer punkt dass es
auch tipp nummer eins warum der garten
so pflegeleicht ist ist dass wir ohne
umgraben gärtnern wir haben wirklich
hier in diesem garten nicht einen
zentimeter umgraben das ist alles
komplett auf der wiese neu angelegt ohne
irgendwas zu zerstören an der boden
schichtung und das hilft einem dabei
gerade in den biogarten auf natürliche
art und weise den boden aufzubauen ohne
ihn zu zerstören den boden super
fruchtbar zu halten das bodenleben zu
fördern was da in den beeten existiert
und unkrauts unterdrücken das ist
wirklich so wenn man umgräbt dann crêpes
mansur hadi unkräuter die oben wachsen
nach unten aber ein normaler gartenboden
hat ein quasi unerschöpfliches potenzial
an unkrautsamen und man gräbt dann immer
wieder samen von unten nach oben wie
dann anfang zu keimen und shops hat man
wieder den garten voller unkraut
deswegen achte ich immer darauf dass der
mutterboden unberührt bleibt das heißt
ich werde niemals den boden nach oben
das ist für den boden am besten
ich weiß nicht finden ob ihr euch mit
bodenlebewesen auskennt es gibt ganz
ganz ganz viele unterschiedliche
bodenlebewesen die super wichtig sind
damit ein bio garten auf natürliche art
und weise fruchtbar ist und die sind
jeweils auf ganz unterschiedliche
bodenschichten spezialisierter bohnes in
unterschiedliche schichten gegliedert
die heißen boden horizonte und in jedem
dieser horizonte gibt es ganz
spezialisierte lebewesen es gibt welche
die arbeiten nur an der oberfläche der
obersten auflage von verwelkten blätter
und so weiter und zwei sätzen wie es
gibt welche die quasi nur in tiefen
bodenschichten leben und wenn man
umgräbt dann
geschichte und man ja die obere schicht
nach unten und die untere schicht nach
oben und dann sterben ganz viele
bodenlebewesen das ist sozusagen ein
massengrab für die die brauchen wir aber
in den biogarten es ist alleine schon
wegen der unkraut kontrolle super super
sinnvoll nicht umzugraben und mit der
beta anlege technik die wir hier machen
er sei aber in sehr viel mit kompass ist
das gar kein problem aus einer wiese
egal wo in kürzester zeit ein gemüsebeet
anzulegen das ganz lange fruchtbar
bleibt das unkraut frei ist und das ja
eben auf natürliche art und weise sind
dem boden aufbaut und ich kann gar nicht
genug betonen wie arques uns diese beet
anlegen technik die wir hier verwendet
haben geholfen hat ich kann euch gerne
mal zeigen wie das funktioniert ihr
könnt mir gerne meinen kommentar die
unter dem video da lassen wenn ihr sehen
wollt wie man bete anlegt ich habe mir
überlegt um euch den start ins
gartenjahr möglichst zu erleichtern und
mehr in die hand zu nehmen und das
kartensystem zu zeigen dass ich
entwickelt habe dass ich einen
gemüsegarten bootcamp veranstalten
möchte das ist ein kleiner kostenloser
mini kurs für den ihr euch anmelden
könnt der link ist hier unter dem video
in der video beschreibung das ganze ist
in drei videos aufgeteilt die ich euch
nach und nach freischalten indem mini
kurs also meldet euch da gerne an dann
kann man alle zusammen durchgehend
entsteht auch immer eine ganz tolle
gemeinschaft von ganz vielen
gartenfreunden und es war super viel
spaß also ich freue mich super wenn so
viele wie möglich von euch im bootcamp
mit dabei sind die anmeldung ist wie
gesagt hier unten in der video
beschreibung tipp nummer zwei ist ein
guter pflanzplan ich weiß ich rede die
ganze zeit nur vom pflanzplan aber das
ist was aus mir selber super aktiv den
garten zu strukturieren wenn ich genau
weiß wann ich was wohl pflanze und es
helfen wir vor allem dabei den garten
möglichst effizient zu nutzen das ist
nämlich auch so eine sache man kann auch
in einem kleinen garten super viel
ernten und hat damit natürlich viel
weniger flächen
managen viel weniger aufwand generell
wenn man dafür sorgt dass die beete zu
jedem zeitpunkt optimal genutzt werden
und dass da immer das ganze jahr über
was drauf wächst was man erwarten kann
und dann soweit es eine geerntet ist
gleich das andere gemüse nachricht so
dass das wirklich ein fliegender wechsel
ist das ist der eine punkt warum einen
pflanzplan super wichtig ist und warum
es wichtig ist dass man sich da gedanken
macht dann der zweite punkt man kann
sich super viele krankheiten und
schädlinge ersparen die alm wirklich im
garten die letzten nerv rauben können
indem man zum beispiel eine gute
fruchtfolge ein held auf gute
mischkultur partner achtet und der
dritte punkt warum einen pflanzplan
arbeit spart sind gebündelte aussagen
ich plane dann immer auch dass sich
möglichst viele gemüse an einem tag
aussehe so dass ich das dann an einem
aufwasch up gehandelt habe und dann
möglichst wenig aufwand damit habe
meinen garten zu bestellen in dem ich
eben von vornherein plane okay an dem
tag sehr ich gehören radieschen
knollensellerie und rote beete alle auf
einmal und dann habe ich das erledigt
für die zeit da muss ich nicht jeden tag
nochmal überlegen aber jetzt könnte ich
noch salat und was wenn sich sondern
nicht plane das immer so dass ich meine
aussagen bündele und das berücksichtige
ich auch in meinem garten kann wenn ihr
noch keine pflanzen erstellt habt dann
guckt man hier oben hier habe ich eine
ganze video serie erstellt in der ich
euch wirklich an die hand nehme damit
ihr schritt für schritt euren pflanzplan
erstellen könnt ihr einfach mit mir
zusammen durch und am ende erhaltet ihr
euren fertigen pflanzplan in den händen
ihr könnt euch noch meinen pflanzen
runterladen inhaltlich schon eher
stärker es fix und fertig ausgeklügelt
dann braucht ihr nur noch raus gehen und
los gärtner dann müsst euch nicht den
kopf darüber zerbrechen aber wie gesagt
es ist gar nicht so aufwendig in
pflanzen zu erstellen und mir macht das
auch immer super viel spaß also schaut
hier oben rein dann erkennen wir
zusammen mit unseren pflanzendoktor mein
nächster tipp ist
möglichst viele gemüse direkt ins beet
zu sehen es gibt gemüse bei denen es
sehr sinnvoll ist die vorzuziehen
nächste woche werde ich ein video zum
thema anzucht machen wenn das erschien
ist verlegt ich euch das gerne da oben
in der ecke ist es ist sinnvoll bei
vielen gewesen eine jungpflanzen ansucht
zu machen und ja wirklich dafür zu
sorgen dass die möglichst früh im haus
vorgezogen werden damit die dann in
wachstumsvorsprung haben wenn man sie
aus pflanzt aber wann immer es möglich
ist versuche ich gemüse direkt ins beet
zu sehen das hat den grund dass gemüse
die ihre wurzel gleich direkt im beet
entfalten können ein viel tieferes
wurzelsystem entwickeln als liebchen die
ganz lange in so einem kleinen topf
eingepfercht waren wo sich die mit
museen und sich selber kräuseln und die
gar nicht so tief wurzeln können am
anfang ist es nämlich so dass es kann
man wirklich eins zu eins sagen das
gemüse gepflanzt wurden 1 4 schwächeres
wurzelsystem haben auch wenn sie größer
werden als die direkt ins beet gesetzt
werden und deswegen können die einfach
nicht zu tiefe bodenschichten
erschließen und sich da nicht so viel
was da rausholen das hälfte sind
abhängiger darf und dass man öfter mal
gibt wenn man versucht möglichst aus
gießen zu verzichten wie wir das ja
machen also wir versuchen möglichst gar
nicht mehr zu gießen nachdem die
pflanzen einmal aus dem gröbsten raus
findet also nachdem sie gepflanzt wurden
gießen wir noch ein paar mal ist die
wurzeln wendig angewachsen sind im boden
und danach bekommen die gar kein
gießwasser mehr außer wenn es hart auf
hart kommt ja was eigentlich so gut wie
nie vorkommt also wir versuchen wirklich
den pflanzen das abzugewöhnen dass die
gegossen werden müssen
und da ist es sehr hilfreich wenn die
von selber schon denn sehr tiefes
wurzelsystem entwickelt haben deswegen
versuche ich immer immer immer wann es
möglich ist gemüse direkt ins beet zu
serien stadt die das ganze vorzuziehen
ersparen auch noch nebenbei sehr viel
arbeit melden
jungpflanzen ansucht natürlich auch
wieder zeit kostet mafia du selbst deine
gemüse nicht verwöhnen
damit meine ich das ist nicht so schlau
ist auch wenn es heiß und trocken ist
jeden tag zu gießen weil so feuchteste
den boden immer nur oberflächlich an
deine gemüse bekommen zwar regelmäßig
wasser aber das wasser durch bringt den
boden gar nicht so tief wenn du jeden
tag einfach ein bisschen ist dann bleibt
der boden sehr oberflächlich feucht und
die pflanzen bilden ihre wurzeln da wo
sie wasser bekommen
das heißt die bilden ihre wurzeln an den
oberen bodenschichten und haben gar
keine intentionen wirklich tief zu
wurzeln und sie sich selber wasser zu
erschließen aus den tieferen
bodenschichten sondern werden total
abhängig davon dass sie immer wieder
dieses gießwasser bekommen dass du ihnen
da jeden tag gibt oder alle paar tage
gibt deswegen ich versuche natürlich
überhaupt nicht zu gießen in meinem
garten nach denen die pflanzen einmal
etabliert sind also die jungpflanzen
bekommen von wasser aber danach müssen
sie selber klarkommen und wenn ich mal
diese dann einmal richtig viel so dass
der boden ganz tief durchtränkt ist und
die pflanzen auch den grund haben
wirklich tief mit dem wasser runter zu
wurzeln und sich selber wasser zu
erschließen und zwischendrin zwischen
diesen gis zeiten auch immer mal so
einen trockenheit druck haben der sie
wirklich dazu anregt für sich selber zu
sorgen und nummer fünf ganz ganz ganz
viel milch ich bin ein super fan vom
münchen das hat tausend gründe
der wichtigste grund ist die zwei
wichtigsten gründe sehen dass es den
boden vor verdunstungsschutz wieder ein
thema gießen wenn wir diese marke nicht
halten dann würden wir gießen müssen
dass es wirklich das was den riesen
unterschied macht ich habe dieses jahr
in dem küchengarten hier nicht geholt
weil ich das einfach mal ausprobieren
wollte wie wer was für ein unterschied
ist wirklich macht und der unterschied
war nur wenn ich hier nicht gegossen
hätte im sommer dann
nichts gewachsen auf unserem acker im
vergleich dazu haben wir überhaupt nicht
wissen nicht mal beim serien also wir
haben dann weil wir da keinen
wasseranschluss haben wirklich darauf
achte dass wir immer nur sehen wenn es
gerade regnet die pflanzen sind
aufgegangen weil es da eine periode lang
feucht war und haben danach überhaupt
nicht mehr gegossen und trotzdem super
viel geerntet wir hatten noch nie so
viele kartoffeln zb wird service wie wir
da jetzt auf dem anger geerntet haben
komplett ohne gießen einfach durch eine
dicke dicke dicke mulchschicht und
natürlich dadurch dass wir die beete so
anlegen wie wir sie anlegen stichwort
kommen ins bootcamp infrage ich glaube
es geht erhalten wo ich hab' noch viel
mehr tolle positive aspekte die er mit
sich bringt zb schwitzt in den boden vor
erosion vor wind for better so da wird
nichts weggeschwemmt oder weggeweht der
boden ist immer bedeckt die
bodenlebewesen halbmast futtern der
ruhig verrottet nach und nach zu compass
das baut den boden auf die bodenstruktur
das dünkt die pflanze also es gibt ganz
ganz ganz viele gründe warum es sinnvoll
ist die beete zu mulchen und nachdem
dieses jahr hier ohne wo ich im krieg
gaben so viel aufwendiger war bin ich
super froh dass jetzt ein neues jahr
angebrochen ist das mein experiment zu
ende
und dass ich da hin zu vielen wurde ich
drauf kippen kann wie nur irgendwie geht
und da sieht man wirklich auch im sommer
wenn es wochenlang nicht geregnet hat
wenn ich da den mut zur seite und ein
bisschen mit den händen in der erde
wühlen die darunter liegt ist immer noch
feucht egal ob es wochenlang
staubtrocken war ob wir nur temperaturen
über 30 grad hatten ihr wisst wie die
letzten sommer so war es ist unglaublich
was diese mulchschicht aus macht also
nicht euren garten wirklich ich kann ja
ich bin absolut ruhig vor ich hoffe du
bist im gemüsegarten bootcamp mit dabei
der link ist unter diesem video in der
video beschreibung ich freue mich schon
wahnsinnig darauf mit euch mit diesem
boot camp ins neue gartenjahr zu starten
wenn du bist möchtest du vielleicht
unseren selbstversorgung mit hühnern mit
ziegen mit brotbacken und so weiter
insgesamt kostet also nicht nur der
garten dann schau dir gerne in dieses
video an da drüben selig das ganz genau
also da lässt sich wirklich auf wie
viele stunden pro woche und welche
aufgaben kosten das ist ganz spannend
für alle die das ausprobieren weil die
einrichtung selbstversorgung gehen
wollen da unten findest du auch noch ein
spannendes video wir sehen uns nächste
woche wieder macht's gut